fallout 4 is out tomorrow and as with
any good Bethesda RPG there are hundreds
of ways you can choose to play it some a
little more unorthodox and others I'm
talking killing every single person in
the game or choosing to go to learn
without the use of guns in the spirit of
that here are five epic and strange ways
that you can play your favorite games to
give you some inspiration a ganun can't
be defeated in 1986 with the legend of
zelda without the use of a sword it is
possible to ignore the old man at the
start of the game and go at swordless
until that point it may have been
dangerous but evidently it is possible
to go alone through the entire game
until the gannon battle without using a
sword if you try this out expect to
become very close with your shield and
ranged weapons a number of people who've
attempted this one also did so without
using killing items just in case the
whole no sword thing seemed likely to be
way too easy for you telia dwyer has
recently been taking on fallout three
with no armor and no guns as it happens
Dark Souls is also a game that's bloody
hard to play with no clothes on weapons
the Box are challenged calls for
confident participants to take on all
their foes with only their fists some
people decided to add extra restrictions
on top of that including no pyromancy no
shields no carrying and in some cases
new clothes Dark Souls has also lent
itself to a bunch of awesome
playthroughs that while they may feature
fairly traditional play styles are
strange in a whole of the way gamers
have played the brutal action game using
controllers that range from guitar hero
guitars and rock band drums two steering
wheels and even bongos the videos are as
fascinating as they are absurd and yes
before you ask someone has also played
dark souls with all the games movement
found to a dance pad now this next one
is probably the one weird way of playing
a game that you've definitely
encountered before while car theft and
serial murders are rampant in grand
theft auto you can also decide to play
the game as a law-abiding citizen while
GTA 5 is a criminal sandbox it's also a
pretty spot-on simulation of a
functioning city complete with traffic
lights cops and even laws that you can
follow you know if you want to it might
not be the most exciting thing to watch
but it is totally doable just simply
cruise about the city taking in the
sights obeying traffic laws and paying
shopkeepers for their wares instead of
threatening them for the contents of the
cash register mass effect is pretty much
all guns all the time but at least one
gamer decided to ignore all that adopt
for less traditional methods of
destruction taking on mass effect
without guns involves using a lot of
biotic and tech powers mines are
grenades and of course the front bumper
of the Mako it actually works a lot
better than you'd expect Sean who took
on the challenge on YouTube also took a
number of measures to keep his
companions from doing gun damage where
possible he selected companions who were
untrained in guns and if there was no
other option he equips them with guns
that they were as untrained in as
possible so they wouldn't be able to do
any real damage with them that said you
can't actually get your characters to
put their guns away so they often just
look like they've simply forgotten how
to use them video games are pretty big
on chickens getting revenge whether
they're exploding in Skyrim or ganging
up on you in the Legend of Zelda this
dire blue player took it one step
further opting for a witch doctor and
then spamming hex to turn yourself into
a chicken is basically the foundation of
this playthrough youtuber noxious who
took on the challenge also kitted out
his bowel with a finely tuned skill set
to enable a shitload of exploding and
poison damage so even on the highest
difficulties he ended up with a very
speedy and pretty fearsome badass
chicken let me know down in the comments
if you've ever tried out an unusual play
style in a game you love and how you're
planning to play fallout 4 I will catch
you again next week